[Music]
Milana is one of our favorite Disney
Princesses but do you really know what
happened to her make sure you watch this
video until the end to know what
Polynesian people think about this movie
if you love Moana as much as we do don't
forget to subscribe and please give this
video a big thumbs up today we are
showing you the disturbing real story
behind Moana who is Maui while Moana
isn't part of the Polynesian mythology
the Disney movie was actually inspired
by another character Maui we can find
this demigod in many cultures but the
creator's decided to focus more on the
Polynesian mythology however when they
first looked at in many people didn't
recognize him that's because Maui was
supposed to be a slim young man coming
of age with a topknot on his head we
don't know what Disney did to him but he
ended up being huge and covered with
tattoos with long flowing hair on his
shoulders actually the animators first
wanted Maui to be much thinner involved
but they chose to change his physical
appearance to make him look more heroic
many people were upset with that choice
but we'll talk about this later Maui's
family looks really different too in
mythology Maui actually had four
brothers he was also the son of a god
and a mortal woman making him a demigod
unlike what we see in the movie where he
was abandoned by his parents and raised
by a God but just because he was a
demigod doesn't mean that he was all
good actually the original story
involved much violent stuff and things
that should have only been seen by
adults this is why it was left out of
the film that was meant to be seen by
children but there are actually some
things that Maui can be proud of what
really happened
what did Maui do to be so popular in
many cultures the best-known myth was
that the demigod was the one who created
the islands it all started when Maui
convinced his brothers to go on a
fishing trip but the demigod caught his
magical fishing hook on the ocean floor
this was when he told his brothers that
they should paddle as hard as they could
because they had caught a big fish they
paddled so hard that they shored up
several islands that would later make up
the islands of Hawaii and many other
islands in another version of the story
he actually caught a huge fish but his
brothers opened it without his
permission and it broke up into
mountains cliffs and valleys the legend
says that if they had waited to open it
the islands would have
plain flat one of his biggest
accomplishments was also restraining the
Sun when he lassoed it with his sister's
hair he wouldn't let it go until the Sun
agreed to give them long days in the
summer and short days in the winter in
the Hawaiian culture Maui is also
responsible for passing the secret of
fire to humans we actually hear about
many of these stories in the song you're
welcome but it was really easy to miss
if you didn't know anything about the
Polynesian culture but no matter what
there are some things that Disney got
right in this movie what is right
Disney has often been accused of being
insensitive with cultures mostly when
they turned Pocahontas 'as tragic story
into a fairy tale but this time the
creator's wanted to make people proud
they have been interested in the demigod
Maui but Disney Animation chief told
them to go research before doing
anything this is why the creators went
to Polynesia many times to meet a group
of anthropologists cultural
practitioners historians linguists and
choreographers these people help them
make sure that the story was accurate
this is why they deleted a scene where
Moana threw a temper tantrum and hurled
coconuts down on the sand because it was
considered to be extremely offensive
they are also the ones who said that
Maui couldn't be bald because that's
where the power of the demigod came from
during their first trip the creators
also saw that Polynesian women were so
beautiful that they should make the
story about one of them this is how
Mawlana was created Disney also cast
Hawaiian voice actors who were
encouraged to rewrite the lines to add
more accurate Hawaiian slang this is how
there are some things that they actually
got right people love to see that Moana
was a strong Disney Princess who didn't
need a prince they took the time to show
some Polynesian traditions and they made
sure that the community was the most
important part of the story but can we
really forgive them after all the things
they did wrong what is wrong when people
learned that Disney was making a movie
about a princess from a different origin
many people were getting ready to be
offended and one of the first things
that shocked them was how Maui looked as
we have said before the demigod was
supposed to be a teenager on the verge
of manhood but he was illustrated as a
kind of buffoon and some people thought
that he looked kind of stupid others
were also offended by his size as they
said it perpetuated offensive images of
Polynesians as overweight
some people didn't even want their kids
to watch the movie because of that it
just got worse when Disney created a
cost
of Maui featuring a tattooed body
stocking it is not a surprise that this
brown face caused a big controversy
people also didn't like how coconuts
were used as a caricature of Pacific
people it just got worse when they
depicted a whole race of people the
Camorra as evil coconuts but the problem
is that according to the legend they
were simply short statured people of the
Solomon Islands Disney had no right to
portray them like that and let's not
forget that coconut can also be a racial
slur against people from the Pacific
Islands and these are only some of the
things that offended them what
Polynesian people think but what do
Polynesian people have to say about this
will Varner from BuzzFeed ask some of
his friends to talk about Moana when the
movie came out some of them were excited
to see people like them on the big
screen while others were getting ready
to be offended but they did love a lot
of things about the movie like the
grandma the raw colour and beauty of the
islands the songs and the community they
also all agree that their favorite
character was Moana however there are
still some things that they didn't like
it is not a surprise that many of them
didn't like how Maui looked one of them
also noted that women couldn't become
chief in the Tongan culture surprisingly
many of them didn't like the giant crab
and one also said that coconuts just
aren't scary but no matter what if they
could change one thing that would
probably be some voice actors or the
sound of the choir oh and one of them
couldn't handle the chicken and another
still argued that women can't become
chief but overall they had to admit that
it wasn't that bad what do you think
about Moana do you think that Disney did
a good job or they should have stuck to
the real story don't be shy to answer in
the comment section down below we love
to hear what you think and that's it for
the disturbing real story behind Moana
if you liked this video don't forget to
subscribe and please give us a big
thumbs up thanks for watching and see
you next time
[Music]